don't they have certain limitations on
how much money they can lend based on
reserves yeah lever limits right right
there's a it's 40 cents on a dollar i i
want to say insurance is 40 cents i
don't know
banks obviously can leverage a ton more
where they're you know the numbers the
expectation isn't as high
but they have a certain number they have
to go off right well it does depend and
and really this
um this point that you're raising is an
important one you know what's what's the
story with these bank reserves and
reserve requirements and isn't that a
way for the central bank to actually
control it so ultimately the central
bank is
is really fine-tuning the money supply
well it doesn't quite work that way
and you can see this immediately when
you look at many countries such as the
uk
um but also
australia new zealand um in fact many
countries nowadays
have zero reserve requirements so then
you realize well okay the reserve
requires can't be the key story the zero
um
what we many countries have zero reserve
requirements yes any of these countries
are any of the bigger you know countries
in the world yep such as the uk uk zero
it's been zero for for decades so who
holds them accountable on the amount of
money they can lend yes well there is
actually another variable that's been
used
um to influence banks and actually it's
a good point perhaps let's let's go
quickly through this
i mean i'm professor of banking and i
was astonished to find that the experts
the textbooks
um
the researchers weren't even sure how
banks actually work
and i found that there's three theories
of banking three theories of how banking
works and when we when we talk about
banking the key function that
distinguishes banks from others is
actually in their lending operations
and the key question there is where does
the money come from
actually one of my books where does
money come from you know
has this title and so where does the
money come from that the banks
use when they give out a loan and that's
where the three theories of banking are
different from each other
now the the currently dominant one the
mainstream theory that is pushed in the
textbooks is oh banks
um they're not very special you know
nothing to see here move on
there's nothing special about banks
they're just financial intermediaries
that's the financial intermediation
uh theory of banking
and they say banks lend out their
deposits right savings on the left loans
on the right just in the middle yes yes
exactly and with that theory what
regulatory tool to control banks is
being used is actually
capital requirements
um so since the basel accords in the um
late 1980s it's been capital that's been
used mainly to
get a handle on what banks are doing and
the idea is that this will control and
restrict banks activities so we won't
have banking crises well has that worked
have we had banking crises since 1988
tons of them in fact dozens and dozens
if you look at the whole globe we had
um for some that don't know you were
with bear stearns for 14 years or 13
years right
not that long but i was at best earns
asset management uh senior managing
director senior portfolio manager i was
also at jardine fleming securities uh
before in in japan
um as chief economist
the reason why i say that is to say
you're not just a professor because
sometimes you know a professor is seen
as
you know the intellect who just stands
up and talks and has never been in the
operating room that's doing the work
you've been
you know in both places yeah precisely
and in fact that's the whole point
because i realized these
um academics and and their theories are
mostly wrong
and we have to hold them to account and
we have to actually ask the question
what is reality how do things really
work so this theory that banks are just
intermediaries um they gather deposits
they lend out those deposits and we can
use therefore bank capital requirements
as a tool to keep the banks under
control
is plain wrong
we'll come to that there's a second
theory that's an older one that was
dominant from the 1930s to 1960s
and that is the fractional reserve
theory of banking now a lot of people
have heard this and i'm sure you have
because you mentioned the reserve
requirement and that's important in this
theory this theory says when a bank
lends money
it needs to have some excess reserves
and it will be using those for the new
lending
and you know if banks are all loaned up
with their reserve requirements they
can't give out new loans so they first
need to have some excess reserves that
could be from the central bank helping
them but that's the mechanics
now um that theory was dominant until
the 60s
and it did have an interesting feature
that got a lot of people interested in
this namely the so-called money
multiplier so it says that each
individual bank is just an intermediary
they gather deposits and lend them out
but in aggregate as banks interact using
this reserve requirement somehow there
is
leverage money creation happening and
therefore there's a money multiplier
there now that theory
actually
gave away the fact that there's
something strange happening and banks
create money and that was too much for
the powers that be to handle that's why
since the 60s they've pushed the
financial intermediate theory which says
oh there's nothing to see here at all
money creation oh no no it's not
happening
but there's a third theory and that's
the oldest
and as it turns out the one that's
really true
it's the one that sounds initially
slightly crazy but it was dominant until
the 1920s 1930s and that one said that
oh no banks are not intermediaries
they're not financial intermediaries
banks are creators of money
if you get a loan this is new money
creation and the bank um
will will create new money into
existence that's the one that that
you're getting when you take out a loan
we could talk about how this actually
works and how they make it work
um but there's these three theories and
that one has been suppressed quite a lot
but you also find actually for each of
the three theories you find famous
economists supporting them
um keynes
john maynard keynes the famous 20th
century british economist
he actually supported
all of them in sequence
now he moved
first he supported when he was young the
the credit creation theory the banks
created money out of nothing later he
moved on to the um
fractional reserve theory and then even
the financial intimidation theory so he
moved away from the truth as it turns
out now i thought well this is
ridiculous we've got three theories
which one is true what's the scientific
thing to do let's look at the data let's
look at the facts let's do an empirical
test
so i conducted the first empirical tests
of
banking and how do banks actually work
and which of the theories of banking is
true
which was the first empirical test in
the 5 000 year history of banking if you
want
you can actually get this online if you
just google
one paper is entitled
can banks individually create money out
of nothing
can banks create money out of nothing
yeah individually created
them yes because in aggregate you see
that would be one of the theories but
actually individually
out of nothing that's the most radical
one that's the credit creation one
that's it that's it exactly
um and secondly um the other paper is
called lost century in economics
um
that one also has the three theories of
banking has another empirical test these
are two different types of empirical
tests and that's the one and the
conclusion is that
the current dominant theory that banks
such as financial intermediaries that
one is rejected
by the empirical evidence and also the
theory that
um the fractional reserve uh argument
money multiplier holds has also rejected
and the only one that is supported by
the empirical evidence is the credit
creation theories banks create money out
of nothing so it's now an empirically
established fact
but who again who holds them accountable
though
so banks create money out of nothing
who holds them accountable everybody has
somebody to be held accountable to who
are they being held accountable to
that's right now that's where it gets
interesting and we can go back to japan
now um because once you realize well wow
this is how powerful banks are
because that you see their their
decision who gets new money who gets a
loan you know means somebody gets new
money that didn't exist before and that
will have an impact on the economy and
the question is also what is it going to
be used for which types of transactions
is it going to be for consumption if and
banks usually copy each other so if the
banks lend a lot for consumption then
you will get inflation that's something
we need to talk about later because
that's what we're currently getting and
you know i've been warning since 2020
that we'll get significant inflation now
unlike
for example after the 2008 crisis and
and the bailout measures then it's very
different now this is inflationary um if
banks create money and it's used for
for purchases of ownership rights such
as property real estate or financial
assets you know all these loans to to do
financial
deals
um
that will push up asset prices because
it's like creating new money say let's
let's look at real estate property um if
banks give out a lot of uh property
loans and real estate loans
it's like printing money and pumping it
into the property market what's gonna
happen right you don't need to be a
rocket scientist no okay they're pushing
up asset prices um and the third
possibility and there's only these three
really
the third possibility that's the
redeeming feature of banks if banks
give a loan that means they create
credit they create money and give it to
to a firm for productive business
investment
that implements new ideas new
technologies increases productivity
that gives us economic growth without
inflation that gives us job creation
that gives us uh really what we want
without all the negatives you know
without asset price inflation without uh
consumer price inflation without banking
crises
whereas the other type lending for
consumption and also um bank credit for
asset purchases you know get the acid
bubble and after the asset bubble you
will always get and this is also what
happened in japan of course most
dramatically
you'll get a bust
asset bubble and then a bus banking
system
and when the banks shut down they don't
lend at all then you also don't get
economic growth because for growth we
need new money creation in the system
um and so i i formalized that and tested
that in the early 90s on japan
as the it's the general quantity theory
or the quantity theory of credit of
disaggregated credit where you you
recognize money creation money is
actually credit bank credit that's how
you measure the money supply correctly
you know central banks will always tell
you money supply we don't know what the
money supply is we don't really know the
textbooks also say that we don't know
what money is come on gotta be kidding
me
they just didn't want to tell you right
the true story it is bank credit we can
measure it it can be identified quite
clearly
and the question is what is this being
used for
and so if it's used for productive
purposes that's when you get
job creation growth no inflation
um you get all the positive things and
not the negative things acid bubbles
banking crises increased inequality and
inflation all that these things that's
when it's used for unproductive and
therefore unsustainable purposes and of
course there's something we should talk
about later as well
how can you have a banking system that
does
the right things and therefore supports
the economy best it's when you have
many many small banks local banks
community banks and that explains why
the u.s economy despite the various bad
government policies that have been going
on for a long time is still
fundamentally quite strong
the strength the secret of the strength
of the u.s economy and also actually the
german economy for the last 200 years
and also the japanese economy is because
they've got hundreds
if not thousands of small local
community banks banks that lent mainly
to small firms because the small firms
mostly engage in productive business
investment which creates jobs gives you
growth without the bad stuff without the
inflation without the acid bubbles
and banking crisis and so on but of
course you know
things can also go wrong particularly
again when the central banks intervene
so back to your question so who's who's
controlling these banks i mean how does
it work well
what i found out in japan it was a bit
of a detective story
first i realized wow this okay this is
this house of cards is going to come
down now because they had all these
property loans real estate loans
in the 80s pushing up
land prices to stratospheric levels in
central tokyo
the
palace imperial palace garden
part of that is a public park and people
calculated okay that's a central tokyo
public park not that big but you know
okay
um what is the value if we use central
tokyo land prices and it turned out that
the value was the same as the entire all
the property real estate of the state of
california including los angeles san
francisco everything
which was crazy that was in 1989 that
was can you say that
i don't think the audience say that one
more time
so the asset prices were pushed up the
land price in japan were pushed up
through this mechanism yeah bank credit
for land purchases and property
transactions so much that at the peak
which is 1989
the um only a tiny speck of land in
central tokyo namely the imperial palace
garden they calculated you know the the
the size the the footage okay it's this
big what is the value using market
prices of central tokyo and it turned
out it was
the same value as the entire state of
california so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]